i want to do a quick follow-up to the
last video because i did not give a
complete picture of all of the fiscal
policy tools that a government has at
its disposal what i what i focused on in
the last video is a government that
holds taxes constant
taxes constant
and
increases spending spending
spending
goes up and the only way that a
government could do that is by taking on
more debt or i guess if there's there's
some governments that are saving saving
less but most of them they're going to
have to take on more debt so they're
going to take on more debt and just to
think about it in terms of the in in
terms of the the the gdp expenditure
components we know that gdp
gdp is equal to consumption which is
mostly mostly consumers individuals
investment which is mostly firms and
some consumer spending on new houses and
then you have government expenditure and
then you have net exports which kind of
completes the picture but what we
described in the last video is these two
things are held constant taxes don't
change people the government isn't
fueling its expenditures with more taxes
so this part stays constant but with the
extra debt the government spends more so
this part goes up everything else holds
roughly constant and so gdp
gdp would go up the other tool that the
government has it's at has at its
disposal
is to hold spending constant so spending
spending is held constant and lowering
taxes
and lowering taxes which would
essentially put more money in the hands
of consumers of individuals families and
firms and once again the only way that
they can do that if you hold spending
constant and you're reducing your
revenues the only way that they could do
that is once again taking on more debt
so this is a common theme here so they
would have to take on more debt assuming
that they don't have any savings to
to kind of eat up to finance this type
of thing
and so looking at this again we have gdp
is equal to consumption plus investment
plus government spending plus net
exports plus net exports in this
situation government spending is held
constant but because the consumers and
the firms taxes have gone down they have
more to spend and they will spend some
component of it and so these two pieces
will go up and gdp will go up so i just
wanted to make sure that we added this
picture right over here fiscal policy
isn't just about increasing or
decreasing government spending it can
also be about tax policy increasing or
decreasing taxes